si kevin coster nous fait l'honneur
d'être parmi nous ce soir ce n'est pas
seulement pour rire à messei mais pour
recevoir un césar lui même donneur pour
le lui remettre
nous avons demandé à celui qui à son
instar a reçu deux oscars en même temps
au titre de meilleur réalisateur et de
meilleur film
michel hazanavicius
ce soir
ce qui est bien avec un césar d'honneur
c'est qu'il ya pas de suspense il n'y a
pas de plusieurs nommé pour le césar
d'honneur à kevin costner je pense kevin
costner que vous avez compris que vous
la ville autant les autres césar il faut
il faut s'entraîner à continuer de
sourire en restant assis autant
l'annoncer davantage le désavantage par
contre c'est que on donne pas de césar
d'honneur aux gens très jeunes et ça
veut dire qu'on est peut-être bien
thomas kevin costner dans quelques
instants va regarder un rap et de
montage de vos films c'est très
impressionnant
et là on va vraiment voir ce que c'est
qu'un beau mec un vrai que vous soyez
blonds bruns moustachu par mu moitié
barbu trois quarts barbu avec
rouflaquettes sont remplies de
rouflaquettes avec lunettes sans
lunettes
quoi que vous fassiez vous restez un
beau mec mais vous n'êtes pas beaucoup
de visages vous êtes vraiment beau vous
êtes un des plus grands acteurs
américains vivant vous avez interprété
des rôles mythiques
vous avez marqué l'histoire du cinéma
vous faites partie de la mythologie
moderne et quoi que vous fassiez vous
incarnez quelque chose de bien
quelles que soient vos rôles en plus de
ça vous êtes un pur réalisateur en plus
vous investissez des millions de dollars
pour lutter contre les marées noires en
plus vous avez sept enfants vous êtes
bio en gros vous êtes un héros vous avez
un peu la grosse classe kevin costner ça
doit être super cool d'être kevin
costner en feu
et malgré que vous ayez une histoire
d'amour avec un loup qui s'appelle
chaussettes et qu'on vous ait vu
gambader pendant des heures avec lui
dans une prairie en lui faisant des
papouilles
je suis très fier ou non de l'académie
des césars de vous remettre un césar
d'honneur
mais avant
mais avant et avant de demander à kevin
coster de rejoint de nous rejoindre sur
scène jetons un coup d'oeil à magnéto
qui lui rend hommage
e
ep
voilà ouais
m
je
ou du moins de faire
et m
ok
comment
la gamme
ouais
bon
quand
baran cusack
elle opère
wang
la mairie
culminant
village mais moi vouloir
alors au pays
un des mains sûres merci merci beaucoup
bonsoir
chacun devrait connaître ça au moins une
fois dans sa vie
cet honneur qui en fait ma vie et le
cinéma m'a fait découvrir le maillot
leno je ne connais qu'une longue
mon français tu serais exprimé la
gratitude y aussi pour être acceptée ne
fait aucun doute que je suis américain
aura de mystère ce sont des rejets de
carbone
photo richard et demain que j'ai
toujours choisi mes films en fonction de
leur histoire et nous on fonctionne déjà
à la quête de ce mot scolarité viège
étendue à tous les acteurs
j'ai toujours aimé la magie qui ont tous
la production d'un film
de même des moments notre propre qu'on
n'oubliera jamais ce pauvre peuple
réplique à ce congé est imperceptible de
la sdc mauvais dans la mémoire
deviennent des classiques movistar ce
souhait quand les films touchent ainsi
pourquoi on y retourne
on paie sa place il nous dit aussi nos
vérités cachées ou ne gagne pas toujours
héroïsme peuvent passer inaperçus movie
ce film nous rappelle comme roitg vivre
sa propre vie l'eau sale of your ya les
films la minutie des corps et les
polémiques qu'il suscite
moi même j'ai enfin pu me tillie
travaillent de longues heures sont se
plaindre respect pour les chauffeurs de
seine mulato qui me
amène chez moi tout pour préparer les
repas vous êtes importance et merci pour
compléter ma carrière
il me fallait tourner france / à vis
avec mon réalisateur multi son match nos
deux pays et rencontrer d'autres noms du
cinéma
merci à vous d'avoir accepté pour ce que
je suis merci de m'accepter pour ça
qu'un jeu souhait
je suis en aurez vous ne nous avez
offert à ma femme christine ya un mois
une soirée fantastique
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup